[Music]
like the representatives introduced
themselves and it's a great producers
my name is senator my name is barbara
griffin i'm from
goffstown and i apologize to the
committee i will have to leave a couple
of minutes before too but we'll be right
outside the door if
the vote is needed and maureen mooney
state representatives serving the town
of
merrimack new hampshire i'm james gray
represent district six in the senate
senator bertsol will be here in a few
minutes
and don soucy i represent some district
which is five words of manchester in the
town
i represent the town the fact that i
watched
um representative teresian the house
staff has prepared a
side by side of the differences between
the bill so maybe it makes sense for us
to just go
over and for the public to know what the
differences are with your commission
the house version of 291 made a change
to
657.15 in regards to absentee ballot
procedures
by modifying language at the
end we're providing the list
to the first 60 to have a time period
within it
that provision was removed by the senate
and then the house had a separate
provision in regards to the secretary of
state
looking at absentee ballot request
information
to create a particular report
the senate i think
at least our analysis shows modified it
did it modified the language and it
moved it to a different position it
moved it to a different
place in 657 657 24a
and the procedure itself actually the
report what it was supposed to look at
was changed along with the fact the
senate changed
the i would say analysis task from the
secretary of state to the ag's office
and i do know
that the prime sponsor of 291
has joined the meeting and to pursuant
to house rules that
that person can address the committee of
conference if they so desire
so i don't know whether representative
thinking a possible solution for this
may not be an either
it may be an ant it would seem to me a
logical solution
is for the house version to take
the first step with secretary of state
reviewing the information
under rsa 657-15
because of the sentence in in that
statute that says
said clerk shall keep the lists of the
names and addresses arranged
by voting places of all applicants to
whom
the official absentee ballots have been
sent and shall identify
the official absentee ballots which have
been returned to the clark
and shall second uh record the absentee
voter applications
information in the statewide centralized
voter registration database
the issue is if the secretary of state
could do that analysis under
the sending of absentee ballot statute
if there is any issues with it
that's where the senate version
of this bill under rsa 657
24 which is the misuse of absentee
ballot
section that seems to make the most
sense to me
um until
there is evidence of misuse
i'm not sure why we would
have that attorney general
review of the of the ballots and that's
why i thought
it would make sense to almost merge both
of these
so that the secretary of state would do
the initial analysis using the statewide
centralized voter
registration database and then if
the head of the election law in the
house and the head of the election law
and the senate see that there is
evidence
or reason to question the
misuse of the absentee ballot that's
when the senate version would kick
in that if that makes any sense at all
i also have quickly two concerns
one is whether the attorney general
has access to those uh
the statewide centralized voter
registration database
without a court order and
i also wondered why the senate
removed the protection for
those voters that have presented to the
supervisors
uh valid protection orders uh under rsa
173b
i'm concerned that if the attorney
general
does the analysis and it is subject to
91a
that that information would then become
non-protected for those those victims of
abuse or why whatever reason that
they're on that list
so those were those were my concerns but
i don't think that they
replace each other i think they would
thank you so much right
certainly the vision when i rewrote
your bill and you know you and i talked
a couple of different times
about it is that
the secretary of state would cause a
report to be
generated out of the centralized
database
which contained the information needed
for the attorney general's
investigator to do just what
the representative uh was asking for
two years ago three years ago i forget
and that it would have more meaning
if the data was reviewed by
a third-party non-partisan party
and found to be good or found to be
lacking
the access to the names the access to
the
agents the access to other information
that is in there that could be provided
in that report
looking into election laws um
would be available to them as i
somewhere whether it was
the senate floor or whatever if we did
get a list of people
where 10 ballots were sent and they were
all
you know 19 20 21 year old and someone
said well gee that's a college address
i would believe that a lot sooner than
if i got
ages of 67 45
22 you know whatever okay
and one would say you know maybe you
don't have to look any further at those
and the other one would say gee
something's going on
uh and the attorney general uh an
investigator
has other responsibilities for looking
at
problems with the election they are the
ones that get the results
of the cards that go out they are the
ones that have other responsibilities
the secretary of state's office would
have to generate the report
so that they would be following what is
already
allowed for them to do in statute is
i don't know that that's true i don't
know where the secretary
stays again you know they have
broad authority in in elections
to to work with people and as it says
that
the data is going to come out of the
centralized database
whether you know who writes the report
is immaterial to me
as long as the person doing the review
so uh for myself on the senate side i'm
comfortable with words
the way we did it and the reasons for
thank you mr chair um i have a
real problem with the senate version
because and i'm not sure from listening
to to representative hill and senator
gray as to
i think we're sort of talking a merger
and then i think we're sort of talking i
think what the senate is
the ag's office is not a
pi agency the ag's office is contacted
in regards to enforcement of laws when
there is reason to believe that laws
have not been followed they are not
they don't initiate the investigation
because they
think something happens so when you talk
about
the ag's office gets the parts well the
secretary of state
has already done an analysis of the
cards that went out to the absentee
ballot
request locations and been returned and
then they do the report and the
secretary of state who has
the close working relationship with the
clerks is the one who contacts them the
communities to determine
oh yeah mrs smith was really in so and
so when we knew they came back and the
daughter has the same name so the
secretary of state
sort of through their work takes that
off the list
so the secretary of state additionally
the secretary of state when they put the
information together
they're supposed to be the non-partisan
analysis
in regards to what they think might have
happened because the ag's office
ultimately becomes the prosecutorial
body
for the and for the whatever the misuse
might have been
so what you're doing is you're asking
the prosecutor to go out
to see if there's been jaywalking and
then handing him the complaint
to then enforce it and so they sort of
become
the witness in their own investigation
they have
they do have an investigator whose name
i love um
but you know i think the initial
um work should be done by the secretary
of state so
when i was listening to representative
hill what i was thinking
was
section 24 does address more of the
misuse that
and 1a as 15 is really a report
so one option would be to keep one a of
the house version
and then add a provision that says
should the secretary of state determine
there is a probability of misuse of the
absentee
ballot requests then that information
information will be referred to the
attorney general's office
um and and
take the language in regards to the
report being generated that the senate
had which the house version didn't
and add that to the language i mean
that's sort of where
i think we're all trying to get the same
place i just have real concerns about
sending it over to the attorney
my only comment was that when i wrote
this i know that we
put in half a half of an investigator
into the bill
a long time ago to work on election
issues
and that the way i structured the report
um you know if the report is generated
by
in my mind the secretary of state's
office
uh that if that's sorted on how many
you know by address that i can look down
with that list
in about 35 seconds probably you know
and see
well you know it doesn't appear to be a
problem or
or it does you know require further
investigation
and that keeping it at the attorney
general's
office gives me
confidence that the information will be
thrown out
because you know it was shared with
somebody
you know the proper techniques were used
you know in developing the
evidence etc so that a prosecution
you know would not be hampered by
i'd like to just suggest that um we
could get there
if we if we looked at
griffin said using out of the house
language
and perhaps merging the two bills for
example
the house version secretary of state
appropriately has
authority and responsibility look into
this as as the
original intent of the bill was when it
was drafted
was to take a look at only a small slice
of ft ballots
those are requested by mail and then
failed to a different location of what
the individual's individual uh pressing
ballots uh from the address that they
had with the checklist installment
different address
and it doesn't just suggest at that
phase that there is any misuse if
the house version was retained
that could be done and then if there
appears to be misuse the amendment the
senate did
would kick in and investigate that
because
and the current statue seems to me the
attorney general
doesn't have the authority to look into
i i see another aspect that
i think is important in this and that is
that
the the house version requires
a report for absolute ballots that have
essentially two um
two qualifications being followed at one
point and one is they're mailed to an
address other than the address that's on
the voter checklist
and the other is that more than three or
more uh
went no x actually more than three so
four or more
went to the same address and so
there's it's it's addressing that and to
make sure that
you know that there that is being
checked
and i would i would equate this to
if we had a uh
bank or security investigation team
and the investigation team was if we
told them
you just watch and listen
and as long as you don't hear anything
everything's okay
don't bother to go and do an audit go
bother to go check anything
as long as everything appears to be okay
it's okay
and don't do anything but we don't do
that we
ask them to make routine checks routine
audits
statistical analysis and
that in a sense is what we're starting
to do
here is saying this is an area that has
the potential it's not saying that
there's problems
just like a bank examiner when they come
in and examine a bank or
a security organization they don't they
don't
suggest there is fraud they hope there
is not
but they check and so the house version
takes this
and it says let's take this area where
there is potential
that this could be abused and it stays
with the attorney with the secretary of
state
who is the person in charge of elections
in new hampshire it stays with the
secretary of state
if it proves up again comparing it to
the
securities or bank on it if it proves
the audit comes through the bank comes
through fine the securities organization
comes through fine
nothing ever goes beyond that nothing
goes to the attorney general
it just stays right there and that's why
i think
the house version is is good
because it it does that sort of routine
chat
just to make sure to give everybody a
comfort level
that nothing is happening and
i i agree on the senate
side that any investigation but any
investigation
so i i actually uh
like senator hill's suggestion that it
yeah yeah
so some modification in the first
if you look at lines uh seven
through i guess nine ten
okay i don't limit it to one thing
or another okay i i added in there that
they should also look at
a higher percentage
of absentee ballots at one particular
community
senator gray i actually have a question
about that because i'm i did not
understand the sentences written and i'm
sure it's me
you said the analysis shall include but
not be limited to the number of absentee
ballots mailed to a common address
and significant differences
and i guess my question is significant
differences from what
of the number of ballots that were
requested
said your time from what significantly
from each other
so if you if you go into uh
and you have 15 absentee ballot requests
yeah and everybody in the state is
running two or three percent
again just to ask the question why
so they're not related
they're two different things that are
being looked into so two things to say
significant differences in the number of
ballots requested
between cities and towns
again you know well but i i gave them
the concept
and no i i that's why i'm asking because
when i read it i really didn't
understand so so it is
if they have a a much larger percentage
in a particular city or town
we should at least ask the question more
i understand what you asked them to do
thank you for pointing that out and then
and again that's that's the two things
that they have to do with the minimum
they can look into other things i mean
think about you know senate bill 43
okay and you know how we wish that the
law
was a little more liberal right now so
that they could have done that
investigation
you know right off the bat okay and
again
i'm trying to give them a little bit of
wiggle room
that they've got the data they get it
out of the centralized database
and they can look into anything they
think and
not even have to go back to rsa 7
is it 7c6 or something
where the attorney general is authorized
to look into
i cannot support anything that i think
is leaving a door a jar for
interpretation as to what the attorney
general
is supposed to investigate because there
is difference
as to what the term significant
difference means
and there is difference in regards to
what investigation means
and you put the attorney general's
office in a terrible position
when they have to make what is a
prosecutorial
decision as to whether investigators
every community in your own police
department
gets reports of
what people think are fines and the
police
may or may not follow up on that and
in regards to election issues
i'm very concerned about a wide open
door
they are the recipients of what are
thought to be
significant differences to your change
look again i tried to
to rewrite it so that i thought that it
would get through the sun
uh it did you know
i mean if this bill went away it would
not bother me
okay i've got another year before the
yeah representative hill and i had
conversations before i wrote this
and you know i expressed my concerns to
him
um and i'm perfectly willing to
you know keep my the rest of my
committee and
see where they want to go and and you
know come back next year and work on
with them
i i guess mr chair if that's all right
what is the senate's
issues with the language that
representative hill had
without just adding what you've had
um that you don't want the secretary of
state's office to be involved in it at
all
the question is who does who analyzes
the data
and what data they can get okay in the
original bill that was brought forward
two or three years ago uh representative
hill
wanted to get the data first and do the
investigation
okay i think that you know that would be
fine
uh but if i really want to do that
investigation
things like the age of the people
okay as i said you know if they're all
down
in boston on boylston street you know
and it's going to one particular address
down there
and they're all 18 19 20 years old
i have a lot less concern than if there
is a
address down there with 10 people
so there may be just
too many things that we have to resolve
in this to come through
i'd like to make a point if they could i
a merger of the two pieces it seems like
that would satisfy uh
some of the more often one of the other
problems i didn't point out earlier was
that
in the house version private absentee
ballot was to be available
to public inspections after the election
but it also added protections for people
that had restraining orders
uh place an apartment in one aid so that
that they would an agent would be
released
and the senate removed that section so
any investigation done by the attorney
general's
office is protected from okay rsa all
right so that's good so
thanks i will certainly ask the rest of
like
many here you know if they you know
want to entertain anything that you guys
write and and come back and meet again
but i can't i you know well
if i may the language there in the house
as i look at this as kind of a step one
step two process
if consent was agreeable to
the two pieces if again i won't know
whether
i'm amenable to it until i see your
language
okay you know like having the secretary
of state
do the initial you know look through the
data
i don't have a problem with that i don't
know if the rest of the
my side you know has a problem with that
i don't want that investigation done
by people outside of the secretary of
state and attorney general's office
you know for the protection of the data
and protections
uh to try to rewrite something
i don't know what our schedules are i've
already got something that's already
going into thursday
but um
what what we're suggesting is that
we use the language that's here it
doesn't conflict with your senate
language
and that we use the language uh on
on one a use that exact language
because it doesn't reflect the static
language and
um again in in
the intent i understand it and i agree
with
is allowing
as they say you know the sunlight is
that's disinfectant and it goes it's 60
days
after election day uh but when you get
into some of the things in 1a
that's where i want
the investigator whoever isn't doing the
investigation to have a little more
freedom of hands and that's one of the
things representative griffin
didn't want to support okay so i can't
if you're going to give me something you
know
take it based on this conversation write
it
send it to us and reschedule me
if i admit if i may um again i
believe
but again looking at it as a phase one
of doing that
again there's been no misuse
the secretary of state's office looks at
it there's some things that are
problematic
now the language you put in place
[Music]
regarding what the attorney
general's office could do which would
kick in and that could be completed
as you suggested i guess i'd ask one
last question what
what's specifically in the host version
what
what language in there as it's written
is problematic to the senate
specifically um again i wrote that uh
probably two or three months ago now wow
number of absolutely ballots requested
by mail
never sent to an address other than the
check
yes i mean speaking for myself because i
haven't spoken about the bill at this
point
the problem that i have with the house
version is introduced is
lines 17 and 20 now making
the reason that you had to put in the
protective order
provision was because you're now making
something that wasn't public
publicly available so i think
that in and of itself leads to second
guessing potentially of what the
secretary of state and attorney general
is if the idea is solely to do the
investigation then
they're information of any problem will
be made public
but okay um
i can see what you're saying uh i think
the intent of that i don't want to speak
with a
what would be the downside except if we
have a pause in there to protect people
that are under protective order
what would be the problem with
public doing that well they're not
immediate once again so you know if
somebody's away
they're not at their home it's
not something that's currently available
if the purpose of this
law is for the secretary's office and
the attorney general to do an
investigation
then why don't we let them go about
their business if we're now going to
make these lists public it means that
all of the clerks will have to
re-examine
um their list to ensure that if there
are protective orders and i'm sure there
are throughout the city
that they're in compliance with them the
orders are sometimes specific to date
once again it's another layer of
bureaucracy
that may or may not get to anything
all right so i'll kind of throw this out
there and then once the
client so if that language was
17 and 21 away if it would support the
wording of the rest of the
thesis personally i think it's true
the language here is too prescriptive
again i'm willing to consider anything
you guys
write and send me okay i'm happy with
the sentence version of this
i will support the senate's version of
this and that if you
want to do something different i'm not
going to say yes or no on the phone
and i believe that keeping it in
the sec the attorney general's office
protects any investigation any
prosecution that might come from this
i would be willing to go that the
instead of just saying it comes out of
the database of the secretary of state
so prepare it
you know coming out of the database and
i want
a little bit of freedom
in what they're investigating because
you know
i couldn't predict this pandemic no
matter how hard i try
but understand when we're talking about
a committee of conference
it had whatever we put whatever's put
together has to either be
either the senate version the house
version or a combination of both
senator no i'm doing it um
senator bird sells comments about
one thing or the other or
thank you i don't think
that there would be a problem uh taking
the language from one of the other
i don't think there's any additional
language that's that's necessary
i did have a quick comment uh for
senator susie
the reason that that was changed
initially
to require public inspection only with
court order
was as a protection from someone knowing
that someone isn't going to be in that
home
during that time i
mentioned in testimony a couple of times
over a couple of different years
that 60 days is not anything magical
um i don't care if it's 365 days
i don't care if it's the next year it
just seems to me at some point
this information from the election but
not including any of those protective
order
individuals none of that information
should be included
and that was a suggestion from senator
gray
last year i think um
but the 60 days it's magical that could
be anything
um it just seems to me that the
information should be available for the
public to
follow up and say you know gee 23
ballots went to
a high-rise apartment in the center of
boston um
fine and uh and then go check to see
that it's
it's not a college dorm it's a high-rise
luxury apartment in boston
that should be of interest i would think
so
i think you can come up with something
that combines both
parts of this you're talking around each
other actually
um when would you be available
would would uh thursday morning be a
possibility before session
[Music]
just to add i think you should
absolutely have one more attempt
at a mutual draft i think the house side
would be more than willing to contact
ols and get that amendment started and
circulated
among the senators and i'm sure
scheduling we could figure out
afterwards by thought with their
assistance and so on
thank you so much then
many members i am
but i now i have an 8 30
thursday morning i think i'm done
what when is there a deadline when this
happens
thursday tuesday to sign off and that's
the house version is a perfect step one
and it seems like the senate virgin just
amazing observation
is a set there's a part two is extension
and so i think that easily they can be
matched together and we'll do our best
to make that happen and work with your
staff to hopefully meet again by
all right with that you're going to have
to contact uh set at the house clerk
anyway to
right to find the time so yeah all right
we'll see what we can offer the time
between
[Music]
right there's no more comments or
it's it's
great
if
representative from rochester
i'm representative peter trojan i
represent the town of atkinson
glastown rockingham county 14.
representative prosper
represents southern manchester in the
town of litchfield
and i'm representative of ryan of derek
i am james gray i represent district 6.
i'm regina bertsell i represent the
streaming team which is the towns of
derry hampstead and william i'm donna
soucy i represent five boards in the
city of manchester and also the town
all right uh let's begin with
uh perhaps that one of the senators
would like to explain
some of the changes that you've made
first that i was introduced to this
service woman
eight contacted me she was having
problems getting one of the lists from
the town
park and trying to get that
electronically
with that information and what was in
the
bill that came here um
i told her that hey she shouldn't have
to pay for it because if it
was given to her electronically rsr 91a
already says that uh pretty much if
unless they're putting on a thumb drive
and then they can charge you a
reasonable
fee for the thumb drive but that
shouldn't be any more than five or ten
products
uh that they should be able to get it so
i tried to pare this down
to just the essentials on here is that
if they have the right to get it they
can get it
and get it electronically and that
the things about the pain you know
that you didn't have to pay ahead of
time and all that all
disappear you know when you get it
electronic
are there any members of the house madam
chair yes
thank you so basically the two
kind of hit on the two differences
between the two versions
one is that the house version prohibits
the clerks from requiring
a free payment from the list and
gives seven days to pay for the
information
so perhaps somebody else the house might
like to comment on why that
would be a good thing um well i'm the
prime sponsor on this one
so let me kind of explain um my
rationale and the way i wanted this
crafted so i tried to craft the least
objectionable
um way to get list possible so currently
they can charge for the list um i i
didn't want to wait into that
i personally agree that they should be
charging for something that they already
have electronically and producing
electronically
but i didn't want to wade into that
world i wanted to try to give us the
best
work method of passing so
if you guys are readable to just drop in
the payment entirely
um i'm all on board with that that's
really not an issue with me
that was in there to make this more
palatable to everybody but apparently
that's
made it unpalatable so i have no problem
with that leaving
um i do have a
question and then one issue so the
question is is why was it changed to
talk about
the state centralized voter registration
database versus the list that the clerks
keep
so that's question one um and my issue
which will remark up is the language of
may instead of shout
because they the whole purpose of the
bill is shall
and by putting in may in my at least the
way i read it and i'm totally up to be
told why i'm wrong
because that basically uh makes the
uh the reason that i went to the
centralized database is
that was the resolution that we came up
with the woman that contacted senator
ward originally is that the clerk was
the one that was telling him no
and when i contacted the secretary of
state
and we went over the rsa he says that's
not a problem
i'll take care of that we can get that
information right out of the centralized
database
so if the information is in there which
even
you know the voter rolls are in there
after a period of time
because they take the information off of
the
check-in list and enter it into the
database
so there's a wealth of information that
are in there that is in there
changing uh if requested this list may
you know i guess the reason i left the
may
in there is because of some of the
uh clerks in the north country okay
okay now you know
yeah i guess i wouldn't go from may to
shao
unless i had some kind of weasel word to
take care of the people
in yeah small towns graceville notch
i'll make a brand new
okay i think that's everything
that does everything on paper you know
or
you know still has an ibm's electric you
know that they type stuff on
uh and that's the reason that
probably injured my mind as i was
writing this from
you know not saying shall because they
may not be capable of doing it
but also there there wouldn't be many
people on that list
so the cost of it at 50 cents a page
which is what
the judicial system uh
has been charging and and we've copied
that you know through other things
what if you did something with
qualifying language that said
if if an electronic copy exists they
shall provide
to me i was just writing yeah
i didn't even do it i'm sensitive to
some degrees concerned and tried to
address
without charge because if we don't
what's to prevent
downforce from charging rsa 91a already
i think covers that fairly well
i see pam over there shaking their heads
yeah i just don't know i don't think i'm
lying
okay
that's my fair share of those i think
now
remember rsa918 i've had people go in
with their own
copy machines i have had people go in
with scanners
i've had people go in with cameras okay
and so there's any number of ways to get
the information
um and you know this case
you know with that list um you know if
you had a scanner and scan it to a pdf
file
that's an electronic copy so again
you know as long as uh
you know the the town or city you know
purchases a bunch of thumb drives and
sells them to you
you know at or near cost
we're not we're not talking a lot of
dollars yeah the others i brought up
because i've had some
time books so they want to charge for
this that's it's all good and i agree
that we had one of those in just
participate
okay and that all it took is
a couple of minutes conversation with
deputy secretary of state
and it was resolved i i've had those
conversations but they didn't bear as
much further shorts which is why
this exists maybe maybe you know
they used to use a sawdust when they
were
speak for everybody outside but that we
could live with with that
you know fee and did i hear that maybe
you could tighten the link a little bit
from
if we kind of eliminate the
paid piece of it or um
or not specify right now we can see i
think we can see how it works and if we
are um maybe charging then maybe we can
address that
okay so i'm sorry
would this language work uh
if requested and if the list is
available electronically the list
shall be supplied electronic truck
electronically
at no charge to the opposite and it just
simply makes it clear in election law
i can't beat that because they need to
be able to charge for that thumb drive
okay that's again settled stuff that
we've done in rsa-91a
but you can also and electronically you
so maybe it needs to be specified even
further down
that if it's a thumb drive they can
charge if it's
um via email but you could say
physical electronic copy which i know
sounds weird but would send the message
of
if they're asking for a cd or a thumb
drive that then they can charge but if
which try to make it easier on him okay
any charge will be in accordance with
rsa 91a
i think that might do it for uh
your committee assistant and me and a
couple other people too
that's that's that's fine that's fine on
my end but then i would need to see
the language about um the prepayment put
back
in because there is there's time
sensitive to this list
and i have had a town clerk say i will
not give you this list until i have my
money
in hand um and i will only give it to
you in paper
so i i it's i that's why those triggers
are in there because an absentee ballot
list
seven days later is worthless that that
basketball has gone out and has been
returned
it is over i understand
that we have some clerks out there
that don't understand the rules as well
as others
but i mean we're taking something
that you know even in your version with
only five lines
and my version was uh not quite two
lines
and he's already up to four six
eight maybe that's just my big right
so i'm going to ask the question again
in your language we simply add at the
end of that
so if requested the list may be split
electronically from the information
statewide central life or restriction
database
in accordance with 91a could we add that
just i know it's there but if
to do the minimum requirement
if it says is it your agreement within
accordance
so if it said if requested
and the list is available electronically
it and if you want to put the word
shall in there because we've got the
other qualifying words
these fees consistent with
rsa 91a that's all that's all fine with
me i'm not trying to stop the towns from
getting their due or any of that just
trying to trying to get access to the
list that
candidates are a statewide list
you the parties get to they get it every
eight days
which is not not enough um with the way
with the speed of an absolute ballot
eight days is
it's old it's it's you really if you're
going to run it
so this is focused on the community
yeah this is the community so if you're
in a smaller district you should be able
to go back
in manchester um we have a great clerk
and great staff and they email us every
day
all of the changes um so they email us
and they they bills at the end
of uh they built at the end of the cycle
um and it's great and if every town
in this state or city in the state that
had the capacity to do that did that
that would be awesome but
they don't um and it's a little bit of a
pain sometimes because it comes in pdf
and you have to sit there
and then punch it all out but it gets
the job done and that's part of running
for office and campaign
take a little time out of that um but
other
uh clerks i'm not about to it's over
here but other clerks want you to drive
in
while they're open um which is not
always available for some of us who have
jobs
um show up and if they don't they have
to show up with a notarized list from
from you
with money in their hand um for an
amount that
they don't know what they're going to
charge yet and that can create some
chaos
i'm trying to eliminate the chaos from
the list when the windowless is already
available
just email it um i i don't know why
that's an issue for some parts but it is
so if if if we deal with the
language for the electronic that when
it's available electronically it shall
be supplied
if it's in accordance with the fees of
91a
then electronic without a
disk or a drive would be free that will
deal with it in the vast majority of
city and congress
i would think so yeah and is that
acceptable to use that
that doesn't touch the few towns that
only have a
physical paper list but i think i think
we're covering
probably 90 percent of the towns and 99
percent of the voters that like yeah
i would say so we can we can work
language to that get it out to guys
you know if your amendment you know
it comes out the way you said it but
we could just not have another meeting
yeah okay
with your rules uh i think you guys
we get the language out to you
are there any other things that i need
what would normally happen is that we're
actually two committees here
there's a committee of the house and
that's the committee of the senate and
i've seen the senators both shaking
their heads up and down
which is a good sign and i'll let you
i said this might be my only
[Music]
is that if you think about the rest of
the content of that bill
and the upping of the limit to file the
report
yes not a damn house member would would
you know it would be a very rare
occasion that they would ever even
follow
that's like six or seven towns that's
not that's
18 000 registered voters and then the
census blocks they were set twenty seven
thousand people
so that's not enough for a state rep
that's
a lot you don't know but it's gonna
remember we have a real map right so
and the this is the bill
that uh changed the primary date in new
hampshire
from september and as amended by the
senate to
august um the
in the first place we are
august is is a uh we can live with that
uh we understand your reasons for doing
it i've talked to senator gray at length
about this
and understand the reasons and what the
testimony was
um there were
two changes that we've talked about and
would like to make to it
uh we feel uh one is very minor and that
is to change it from the second week of
august to the first week of august
in the time that a winning candidate of
a primary has
and this is particularly true in in the
statewide races of governor and u.s
senator
and in the and in the house races it's
very important that they have more time
to consolidate their
their support uh after winning a primary
it may or may not be a bitterly
contested primary but
very often they are and it just gives
the winning candidate of either party
a chance to consolidate their support
and the other thing
is that we would like to change the
effective date
uh we currently have it in january of
2023 we'd like to change it to
january of 2022 make it effective for
the next election and i know there's a
concern
about uh the redistricting and how that
might impact it
and we can address those concerns so
that's
uh by way of introduction where we'd be
starting with this so um senators if you
speak to that and then council members
well i have a major concern about
changing the date to january 1st 2022.
um we're going to be in the middle of a
register number one
this past with the changes has passed
the senate by 20 i think it's 24 to
nothing
i'm really and our biggest concern in
the senate is the redistricting piece
um chances are even with redistricting
we may be going forward
so it's going to be a long time before
we get any
clear ideas of what the district's going
to be
so rather than impeding the election in
i think i do think it needs to be passed
2022 and i
understand the concerns
federal side and the governor's side
but i think doing this
in doing a change like this
with the um redistricting is going to
just
be a disaster
i
[Music]
my concern is if we bring it back to 20
january 1st 2022
and we have redistricting and i think
it's going to be a disaster
can i give you some pushback on that
so when you look at registered gain
from 10 years ago there were three
lawsuits that were brought forward
they were all finished up in a month and
i believe they passed participating in
january
of the even year which is effectively
when we would be passing registering
anyways
so those lawsuits were brought forward
they were settled
in in a month um since then there's
obviously been
a lot of new case law about reaching
thankfully not with new hampshire
but on the federal side specifically the
federal courts have
walked away from it um they've actually
given the state legislators even more
latitude than they had 10 years ago um
the only real challenges would come out
of state board which is where they were
settled
last time um so i don't um i appreciate
what you're saying about that i look at
the history and i say all right is this
this is potentially a thing um and i
said when i introduced 98
to your body that i am under no
delusions that
no matter what happens someone somewhere
is bringing a lawsuit forward to some
judge
um it's it's not a statement about what
maps will look like what they could look
like
it's just the nature of the times that
we live in so i'm extraordinarily
appreciative of that statement um
i just think when it's a statement that
i could make every ten years
um regardless of just next year right i
could make that i could sit down in ten
years and say we gotta move this back
because we're gonna get sued
um but it seems to be that
we've never other states have not had
this problem before
even with a second week of august i mean
first week of august
and what would that make the filing
so so if the if the laws passed the laws
passed ostensibly in january
january march april may right january
march april may so that's roughly
four months let's say three just for the
sake of argument to take away
legislative back and forth whatever
so that's three times as long as it took
to settle last time
um in in with
with case law that is now argued not
arguably it is more friendly to state
legislators
the the federal courts and i think was a
decision out of arizona
um said that uh the supreme court said
that
uh drawing district lines is a political
matter to be handled by the political
body
um now that doesn't mean there can't be
state challenges i'm sure there will be
um but if i was bringing a lawsuit
forward federal court would not be where
i would look
um and i can appreciate what you're
saying however
i when i was working on the independent
redistricting commission
a couple years ago in that meeting
i specifically got we got
it's not a fact but they well it's a
fact
that they said no matter if this doesn't
pass
the independent redistricting no matter
who wins the
bodies we're taking you to court so
and i have concerns because i think it's
going to go a lot longer than you think
and i and i can i try to just push back
on one of these
the presumption that it's going to be
done in january
is i don't believe it's
first of all the cities you know they
need to
have time to weigh in and do their own
redistricting
because until you've done that you don't
know how those state rep races
you know are going to to even certainly
you know looking at the constitution
no provision here in new hampshire that
if a town
or city has enough people but then that
seems to conflict a lot of times
especially
you know in small towns that are next to
big towns that are
on either county borders or state
borders
in my district i shouldn't say in my
district but in stratfor county
it's rollinsburg you know there has to
be grouped
to somebody because they can't be by
themselves and then
that affects summer's worth which does
have enough people to have their own
you know again not quite enough for an
even number
and then when you try to meet the plus
or minus 10
that the federal government wants to
hold you to the standard
and you can't really do some of those
things unless
and last time i guess the number that
they told me
was up around 13 to do some of the other
things
which probably could get a waiver or not
be
in trouble with the feds but so
i can be optimistic but you know
yeah i just want to say the house was
certainly not indifferent to the
realities of redistricting when cracking
this legislation
um representative rowan included an
amendment in the bill that did pass the
house
that included trigger language that if
we did not have
the district map settled i believe it
was by april 1st
then this law would not be in effect to
move the primary until the next election
cycle
if the only disagreement from the senate
is that we can't have this next year
because we won't have redistricting done
by the time filing gets placed can we
utilize similar trigger language
in a compromise here where if we do have
the map set
by the time that we need to have filing
next year for an august primary that we
can move forward with an august primary
in 2022
and including in the language of the
bill if we don't have the map set by the
time that we would need to have them set
for an august 2022 primary
move the effective date through a
trigger in the bill to
2024. there's a lot of pieces
there are and i understand that senator
what that actually wasn't the amendment
that was approved by the house
and the reason is i didn't like the idea
that we were passing a bill from this
redistricting because in 10 years it's
been another and 10 years later we've
been having another one
and so as the law currently reads 655
14c says that the secretary of state has
the authority to change the filing
period
if redistricting isn't complete what we
did
is added the language on five to seven
which you left in
that also then allowed the secretary of
state to change
the date of the primary if necessary
and this deals with any redistribution
starting in 2022 going to long beyond
that affects
us uh which means very many monsters
uh but uh probably two more
but anyway if you look at that
that was the intent of this was to put
trigger language in here that will solve
it for every redistricting
and it does because it allows it allows
the secretary of state to change the
filing period
and let's just say you you have a filing
period
in here i when we did the amendment in
the house and we changed it to
the fourth week of june we had changed
the filing period only two months before
that
because we felt that if a candidate
wants to run for office he doesn't have
to wait until he files to start
campaigning
so we had made it two months so if the
secretary of state goes another month
later
then there's still two months if he goes
another two weeks after that
still six weeks and people know by then
if they're going to be running
if it comes to the point that he says
yeah now it's getting too close to the
primary
this gives him the authority to change
the native primary
not only in 2022 but in
2032 and 42 and 52 and 62.
and so i i i believe senator bird so
that
we have we've covered that here allowing
the secretary of state
to make the necessary decision
if redistricting is not accomplished and
by the way
senator gray i do agree with you i
appreciate
uh representative barry's optimism that
he that is up to this
the trigger language for a power that
already exists for the secretary of
state specifically
this question the first half being the
filing date
um so if if that's in there
and it's not my uh you know optimistic
world view what the sun's always shining
um we have language to fix that but
i think we would be we have an
opportunity to get this going now
um and to also solve this question
like representative bruhn said going
forward
um and i can actually make the argument
that it's actually set the president of
even when there is
when there's future legislators sitting
here having this debate in 30 years
they'll be able to look back and say
well they had this problem back in 2022
and
they let the secretary of state decide
and i if i could add i did pass around
the primary dates
and initially when i had
when we were doing the executive session
in the house
i am given the primary dates and i did
it on the basis of
2020 which was substantially different
from this because
many primary dates have been changed
because of copenhagen
this is the these are the primary dates
of what they would have been in 2020 had
the uh had we not had uh covert
and you see primaries the first one
being november prior to the election and
then
march april may june and june and august
be in the heaviest months
and then i just for interest i put in
that
the first week of august is the heaviest
one and then it's
you know a couple of them during the
week and then the second week in the
third week of august
so you know we're most
states recognize this and and most
states are dealing with
they're all dealing with just like we
are
and yet you know their primary dates are
significantly earlier but
13 of them are in office and so
um so anyway senator burton does that
i absolutely support the change in the
day advancing the date and i would be
okay with
the first or second week of august and
very comfortable with that
having granted whoever that this is not
you know in any way of the utmost
granting authority to determine what
filing period is is very different than
legislators saying an election an
election that involves the entire state
can be
changed by one individual based
[Music]
bill's defense we already have that
provision with the presidential primary
where the secretary can choose the date
depending on what other states do
i that i i understand but and that
protect
that actually is for the protection of
our first of the nation
correct yes not necessarily the state
primarily but the concept of allowing
one office to set the date of the
election
is already existing in state law so we
wouldn't be rewriting the wheel here
is that right this is a little
biggest legislator sitting around this
table
you're more comfortable with the secret
state being able to move the actual
primary data or the finally finally the
final i have no issue with the filing
because the filing is relative to
candidates that's not something that
impacts
when voters i mean it making the change
in and of itself of the primary date
i think will require educating voters
and getting them up to speed that they
need to plan differently and accordingly
um our communities are going to have to
make arrangements many use
schools in various public buildings so
they'll have to
ensure that those are ready and
so you you um you i agree with the
obvious there's no question
so uh you genuinely believe
um we know where my head is at i'm
redistricting but you you there's a
generally held position that we won't
have registration sorted out by each
of next year which would be roughly if
secretary of state's ability to move the
filing date that's why i want to ask the
clarifying question because i
in my brain i heard i'm okay with moving
the primary but not the final data
that's
that didn't compute when it went in um
looking back at the filing dates that
we've had
okay like 7th of june seems like one of
the earlier ones that we've had
and so now if we move it from the
second week in september to the first
week in august
i'm actually talking about you know 25th
27th 28th of april
and so now when would i have to have
redistricting done
probably at least a month if not two
months before that
and so now you know i'm back in the you
know the end of february
for the governor to sign it and then
that doesn't really give any
any period of time other than you know
that two months to settle
any lawsuit that might be generated from
that
but it but against senator gray
the in the first place the
your filing period in in your version
is the first week um
yeah so if it if the if the secretary of
state
already has the authority to change the
file
and if he changes the filing date to the
first week of june
then there's still two months between
that in the general election
it changes it to the second or third
week there's
you know there's six or seven weeks
between
the filing date and the general election
and so
and and most likely i think most likely
the secretary of state is going to
shorten the filing period he's not going
to take the first option of changing the
primary
changing the primary would be a last
resort if it gets down to three weeks or
five weeks or something like that
that he would change the primary day and
the other aspect of it is is
if let's say we pass it for 2023
in 2032 this same issue is going to come
up and the secretary of state
is going to have authority to change the
primary date
along with the along with the filing
because that's what's in the
in the final senate version of the law
and so that's already there
and in 2032 it's going to happen he will
have that authority
and i would i would contend that i don't
see it as any less likely that that's
going to be contentious in 2032 than in
2020.
uh it certainly is not less contentious
in 2022 than it was in 2012.
and so i i i would yes could i just add
representatives
the concern is in 2032
if we have passed this law and it goes
into effect on january 1st
of 2023 we know what our timeline is in
our time period
if this law isn't passed no matter how
long the redistricting takes place
we know we have a september primary on
the books
so i think the issue is more trying to
make
two significant changes statewide
at the same time if if we could
settle the redistricting then as i said
i completely support
moving the primary i thought june was a
little early but i complete
one of the reasons that we haven't even
mentioned is i think our state
barely complies with federal law getting
you brought this up because we have to
move um 2022
in regards as it is right now you will
call the ballots
and it won't be the first time we've
been sued for that um so
we're to to further complicate this
already
complicated issue we're moving the date
in 2022
anyways by a week so now we're talking
about another
four weeks right um to just further
complicate that and
to go back to my point um even though i
am an optimist
i i would rather start it up in 2022
when we're at the move anyways then do a
different date of 2022 than we did in
and do a different 2024 than we did in
2022 because that's three separate
changes
and now we now if there is any chance
that moving this
would have an effective voter turnout
now now we are moving
a lot of goal posts um and that's
another reason why i like
i like uh i'm okay with august i'm a
june guy but i'm okay with
august um but i i do not like
with the yugo cabo there i don't like
three moves uh three different dates and
three different cycles and that's not a
big fan of it
and we actually have another house
that we uh retained
that just changes at one week for new
york
because it has to be uh so if if we
don't make this change in 2022 then we
have to resurrect that bill
and get a pass to change it for one week
in 2022
thank um
[Music]
despite my neighbors
and our recess uh back on
senators i didn't know if she was ready
so there's a few things that i didn't i
didn't even realize
until we started talking about it we
have
we're going to have problems with the
redistricting in the cities and towns
because for instance manchester
let's say we get the numbers according
we're not supposed to get the numbers so
august or september
um the town the cities are going to have
to do
their redistricting we can't put in a
bill
even if we have the state rep
maps can't be drawn until the cities are
drawn
um the cities have to draw them and
there may
they may not be even done for the um
and it has to go to the voters so they
may not even be done for the
november elections so now we're pushing
it out
um into possibly
january so
we're going to run it we are going to
run into
a time crunch because if you're if
you're talking about
um pushing possibly pushing um
the redistricting out to
even if we can put a bill in we're going
to do it probably a late bill because
the top the cities aren't going to be
ready
then you're going to have to get the
you're going to have to have the bill
drawn the gov
even if the governor signs it at the end
of february
um then you're going to wind up probably
going to court
if i think we're going to run into a
major time crunch and i think it's going
to be a problem
and they can they can address the city's
issue
better than i can what i just did the
bills
the vehicles already exist um because
they're filed underneath the
representative
um uh oh my god griffin my chair
so sorry i'm so sorry um so it's an
amendment
um but it definitely could be outside of
the ordinary process for sure
um but i think going back to i think the
i think i think the two sides tables are
probably focusing on two different
things which is probably
the issue of the disagreements uh you
guys are
understandably um extremely interested
in the filing date we're extremely
interested in the actual primary
is that a is that a fair statement to
say because you guys are
talking about the window right between
the primary and the
i don't know that we're i mean speaking
of
yeah we're primarily interested in the
implementation of the redistricting
plan right but that's how it's going to
how it's going to how it's going to so
this is the scenario
okay in manchester uh
apparently the ward lines are set up in
the chart
so to change the ward lines you've got
to have
a charter amendment so that's going to
be written
then it's going to be approved by
secretary of state then it's going to be
put on the ballot
whether they could get that done with
the time limit
you know for a con
an election the city election in
november
iffy may be able to do it may not
but then you know you got to get back
it's going to go through the whole
process
so if they miss that november
then they're in probably january or so
before they're even going to be able to
have that election
you know to vote on those board lines
and then
that's when we would be able to start
looking
at how we were going to redistrict both
senate house races that go through
manchester
in the rochester somersworth rollins for
dover area
we know that you have to break something
up because they're olives
you can't do it okay so
and when you take dover and summer's
work together
you've got pretty much a senate district
you know
and then wrongs for then you may need
depending on the numbers you may need
some
other like barrington or something
again you know so but
senator gray i mean this is
this is the norm for every redistricting
year
this isn't unique to this year and in
normal years
we have had our filing period begin in
june
so if the secretary of state
groups the fighting period back to
june for the first wednesday in june
um there is still more time between the
filing period
and the primary than we currently have
between the primary and the general
election
and and that's sort of the issue we're
trying to deal with and
i i i'm i'm i understand that my
compromise
is you know accept the senate position
on this
and then we'll work very diligently on
the bill that you're retaining
in the house to fix any problems that
can come up with that
it could even change the date of the
implementation
but there there is a difference from
redistricting year this year
because you're trying to change the
primary in the middle of it that's
we haven't really changed the primary
date when we've had redistricting
and we've run if i recall uh i don't
think we had in
2010 or 2011 we didn't have a
redistricting unit in 2012.
it's 2012 2012. so
yeah they're there and if we had tried
to move that
primary back then it would have been uh
trouble too
but there is a difference between any
redistricting year because we're trying
we're trying to move you're trying to
move the primary in the same year and
i think it's going to be run into a real
problem that's why
you know the senate position is january
1st 2023
i think there's a lot of problems that
you haven't thought about
but if we could still have an august
primary
in 2022 where filing for candidates
is the same time as it would be anyways
for a september primary in 2022
why can't we agree to an august primary
in 2022
and that's why i said if we take this
bill
whether we change the one thing from
from the second week in august to the
first week in august
leave the effective date to 23 and then
in january you've got your bill that
you've retained okay
and we can make adjustments based on
that bill when i have
more information so
you go we for the effective date
pretty much hard over on the 20th you
know doing it for 23.
okay so if you want to get there
the path to get there is your retained
bill
you've got it you can work on it between
now and january
within the second session you know in
january or whatever the rules and the
house are right now
about passing it and get it to us when
we have more information
so in the scenario though that next
year's primary bill for you acaba
changes
also goes to a comedian conference and
we're here next month
debating the primary date that's four
months away
that's going to be a lot of moving
pieces that we're seeing to be trying to
avoid today
so why can't we just solve it now i i i
i see senator gray's point in that
if we take our
retain bill and we pass that on to the
senate the first
february of next year by then we will
have a lot
better picture of where redistricting is
and
at that point if in the first place the
the bill that that bill deals with one
week change in the primary
just to meet the recovery departments
at that point when we have a better
grasp and where
where the senate probably wouldn't act
on that bill until
march or april you know then
we would have a really good idea and
part of it if part of that fill
we said yeah we're moving the primary
we're moving the effective date of
of the august first primary to 2022
instead of 2023
if that was part of that retained bill
is that i'm hearing you say senator greg
yeah and that we're going to obsess
um to act on retained builds is that
first second third fourth session you
i don't know if it's a set number maybe
two or three it has to be right
i think that really won't send it early
to you so
yeah we can work on it so uh
questions i'm not not totally opposed to
what's being proposed here
uh committee of conference on your end
happens to also be the election law
committee which is convenient
um and i know each of each of you well
and i know you're all honest brokers um
but what are going to be
some of the things we go forward with
this this plan to use this retained bill
what are going to be some of the things
that you guys are going to look at
specifically not i'm not saying it has
to be this or they're not going to do
any that i'm just
i want to get a general sense of the
feel of things that you guys are going
to look for um you know like
for me for like an indicator for me
right if i was sitting in your seat
um i would say well i want to see
something passed out of both bodies by
february
right that would just be something that
like i would draw a line and say
you know if it's not done by then
because that everything that's just for
me
but what would be something you guys
would look at redistricting
in the various cities that are going to
be
those places where either senate
or rep lines are going to go through we
tried not to break up
you know higher offices but i
i guess i don't know an executive
council if i ever
if we ever have one that goes through
nashua
or breaks nashua or manchester up i
don't think there's this issue
so again the ones that i'm going to be
looking
at is how rochester someone's worked
over rollinsford
that area breaks up i'm sure that
senator susie will be looking at
manchester
united we'll be looking at nashua
and those are the big hubs and if
they're moving along quickly
i have no problem in going to um
and august at 22. but again i
i'm not willing to do that now i really
appreciate that
i believe you and i trust all of you
okay so you're you will agree to
changing the date
to the first week of august yeah yeah
and uh
with the current effective date of 23.
with the current effective data 2023
a gentle person's understanding that if
the pathway exists for an effective date
for 2022
full-blown with that that's agreeable
yeah and i can work on that
majority leader but we can work on the
i do know that the secretary of state
has
and certainly it'll depend upon what the
governor does also
but again by the january timeframe when
we're looking at this other
legislation that we'll
on the house side agreement with that i